this is Baker a nuclear test conducted
by the United States in 1946 to evaluate
the effect Atomic weapons had on
warships at sea at first the United
States was unaware of the extent of the
radioactive contamination they had
wrought to decontaminate they initially
just asked Sailors to mop the ships but
it didn't take Dr Stafford Warren long
to realize what they had done he pled
with the Navy to evacuate but here's the
thing the Geiger counters they had on
site could not detect the main threat
plutonium everywhere and so from the
Navy's perspective nothing was wrong it
took a week for Warren to convince
everyone to abandon the cleanup he
finally persuaded them by pulling a fish
out of the ocean and throwing it onto a
photographic plate alive and flapping
around the fish had absorbed so much
plutonium that sitting there on the
plate flapping around it took its own
x-ray this frightening selfie is called
an auto radiograph
[Music]